before we go an adorable stroke of luck
a New York mom gave birth on leap day
over the weekend to a second leap year
baby her first one four-year-old Omri
was born on February 29th 2016 he was
all set to celebrate his birthday when
his mom went into labor hours later herb
ate his baby sister Scout was born great
name Micky batiste is here with the
remarkable story Nicky good morning
Anthony good morning the chances of
having one baby on leap day are more
than one in a thousand so imagine
Brooklyn parents Lindsay and damed
dentex shocked when that happened to
them twice in consecutive leap years are
you gonna share all your toys I'll read
em chip will share more than just toys
with his newborn sister Scout they share
the same rare birthday we just said like
there's no way that that wouldn't ever
happen again so we didn't you joked
about it but we didn't think it really
ever would they were both born on
February 29th leap day only comes around
every four years so Saturday was
technically four year old I'm Reese
first his family had an extra special
party planned but it was postponed when
Scout crashed it started feeling some
pain but I didn't really think much of
it but then about an hour later I
realized that I was in labor
first thing went to him through my mind
was no way could this be happening Dane
dem check says they plan on celebrating
Omri and Scouts birthdays on different
days when it's not leap year but
everytime February 29th rolls around
they'll have a big party for both kids
as for Omri he was happy to celebrate a
day later this year especially since he
got the best gift of all a healthy baby
sister
[Music]
scout was one of four babies born at
that Hospital on leap day and two of the
others were actually twins Dane the dad
says that he was told the last time this
happened
back-to-back consecutively bier babies
was 1960 I think they need to get Scouts
some toys because I'm they didn't seem
so excited about water share that will
change that's a great cake Thank You
Mickey that'll do it for us we'll see
you tomorrow right here at the table
take it easy